[Music]
well reject Nation we have made it to
the end of what if season 2 so far
pretty great are you ready Koy to see if
it sticks The Landing if it doesn't what
if it like the last episode's awful more
like worst saying in the I don't even
know if it could it's been that good
we'll see let's find out guys in the
comments let us know did you think what
if season 2 stuck The Landing sure hope
that response is positive all right guys
leave a like on this video that's your
first order of business also thank you
to prepper for helping us Ed on these
highlights and also a massive thank you
to everyone who became super sexy
rejects that's where you uh join us at
our patreon you sync up your own copy of
what if Will through action watch along
and John and I also cover several things
exclusively over there with highlights
and watch alongs included Coy are you
ready to get into I Want To Know How It
Ends let's find
out
I am Groot season 3 oh there it is sneak
preview no finale ooh one if characters
now Canon that is dope love
that yes all of this reac oneing it's
all what iing look at them all oh I
don't even recall some of that I don't
think some of this has happened yet and
know might season one stuff that is
great I love this yet Marvel barely
promoted the show please talk about this
Marvel now all that effort London
16002 we're back a world at peace thanks
to a hero from an entirely different
Universe Captain Peggy Carter a warrior
out of her own time hot too by the looks
of things this happy hour could use a
little more happiness being single malt
few centuries ahead of schedule of
course he really is supreme any chance
you can offer me a lift home I'd call a
taxi but I left my purse in another
dimension come on Peggy step into my
office theirs was the bond of two Heroes
for nice
reference for like Captain Carter Dr
Steven strange had been on a difficult
journey of his own in his pursuit to
save Christine Palmer he destroyed his
soul the one phenomenal
episode but it was only as the world
collapsed around him that he saw the
error of his ways two legends must band
together to face a threat oh they're
going to be the leaders of this one but
against whom welcome to my humble
abode the sanctum infinum oh okay
upgraded you've been here all alone well
not quite I've been kind of busy with
whom Infinity Ultron I think you know
and Thanos Loki beings of Untold power
help them on destroying their universes
what the hell it's
slow down show but look there is
actually something I need your help with
uh strange I'd rather go home some
Guardian you were it's actually it's a
bit embarrassing to be honest one of
them's escaped how did you know Gremlins
aliens Jurassic
Park I can already hear the Watcher in
toning that meddling in the Multiverse
always a mistake I know he's a fifth
dimensional being with that big head and
that soothing voice that doesn't always
make him right I love how the Cape is so
big it still casts him into like his big
Shadow his own shadow big Shadow on his
face so I I love how Haley's playing her
here but I still want to see that
weakness our bad guy is a she Captain
Carter who I lost her Trail here in the
South Dakota Badlands well kori's a bad
guy to him maybe cuz the power why can't
you just do this because you my friend
are an unknown and
here ah thank you this will work out
pretty well Peggy you you'll go find her
I don't trust him don't trust trust him
is the issue yeah exactly then I'll be
able to bring you both back here and
then I'm out no no no I don't trust her
how will I know it's her oh trust me
you'll know that's a little worrying
he's behaving strange so strangely so
strangely Dr more like doctor strangely
yeah more like Dr what Dr suspicious he
writes the he writes the comments I I'm
an aspiring writer I don't know if you
know that do suspicious over
here skull
Rush cool you here to help for a change
or just to narate the bomb at project
rebirth packed a bigger bang in this
universe I love the mood intention of
this neither you nor Steve Rogers
survived Hydra unleashed the Tess's
Powers won the war and destroyed the
world oh damn this is a terrible world
heavy I get involved you watch it's
about seeing
great well strange found a way to watch
and see he's getting involved making a
difference I like how this season
basically became that hope for Captain
America to go to all the times and do
like things this is what Captain Carter
is yeah it's true like all the gems are
Cur helping multiverses and look how
good the snow looks this so pretty this
looks like old school horror
Disney it is kahori but she's not bad I
mean to some if you insist on ending
this in a fight you will
regret yeah very good that was a good
one is strangers on Red Skull
side I don't think you'd be teamed up
with
skull got damn impeccable
timing let me guess he asked you to help
him save the Multiverse to save it from
you why'd you ask
I'm not a universe killer he
is he's watching right now yep my name
is gordi and I think Gori I thought it
was kahori there's a D in there must be
that delusional or honored us is lying
to you first time we've heard her speak
English I just realized oh
no God damn it strange
nice work finding her for me he wants to
extract her power did he tell you about
the forge just targeting Universe
Killers he's Gathering righteous Heroes
too well for what he's feeding everyone
to the forge
enough why what are you doing strange
he's driven himself mad no strange isn't
trying to save universes he's trying to
resurrect his Universe oh God damn it
Steven you're trying to bring back
Christine aren't you yes I am and if
anyone could understand it's you my god
dude I thought we were passed this but
this is madness a come on Peggy a
Multiverse of Madness you know you do
the same thing for
Steve
Peggy it's
pegy I would never do this for
Steve dude not cool bro not
love Steve Rogers wouldn't want me to
the cost is tooo high in the grand
scheme of things it's a small price to
pay what the hell
man trust me Peggy it's better this way
he hasn't gone full
[Music]
evil oh my God oh my God oh my God what
are we going to get let people out let
let them free
oh [__]
awesome
universes even the dragons
here well that should keep him
busy I lovex and
references like the in The Cabin in the
Woods there's just so much hang on
[Music]
tight they're not doing anything they so
generic
oh no it is his cabin at the W what the
hell it really
is
who
whoa I love this so much starting a
prison riot of universe Killers not my
best idea we got to
go done Slinger
[Music]
Loki the amount of work people are doing
over the holiday break to break down
those scenes I know we just going to go
pretty we're just going nice nice like
nice oh oh it's zombie Wanda's back is
this how we Greenlight the Marvel zombie
show W
Damie Z careful yeah I know zombies are
pretty
[Music]
Universal oh great here we go oh you got
this this not a
problem red versus blue red versus
[Applause]
blue they're trying to eat the
shoe these Circle tracking they just the
the cinematography again oh my God
what's happening who's doing this Loki
what did you do it's not
Meen zombies sounds like
my goddess of death now KN yes the last
woman to demand that of me regretted it
oh darling I'm No Ordinary woman I'm the
goddess of
[Music]
death I am
oh you CL BR I love how crazy this is
It's just leveling up I am as good and
this is all proving a watchu right by
the way yeah
no like if you're going to do this plot
you want to just go like ape [__] with
how big can it get
yeah it's strange he's coming leave them
to the warden let's go yeah man the
structur to this is genius
oh that was so cool redo with The
Advengers Infinity War yes at that
moment he's a [__] Thanos is a [__] in
the one of series is a
[__] he's out the one consistent thing
three episodes for three that's just
season
two oh oh [__] with the infinity oh the
one for season one we'll need that
Infinity that's right the s a chance
against strange
Infinity Monger forgot about that
Cliffhanger who is she it's a little too
powerful sometimes the what Earthly
power is that I don't know what she is
it's just a
tesseract I guess teleportation
[Music]
is I guess not the ultimate power I
shouldn't D strength him yeah just got
him out of the suit yeah which deprived
him of the
powers cool
[Music]
no oh my God what is happening right now
she was already so ultimate these two
ultimate ass
chicks fits like a glove does fit like a
glove fits like a nice nice sports bra
too Captain Gauntlet strange just
started the forge we have to stop him
now before he feeds the prisoners to it
in my opinion not overpowered no just
what do you mean Infinity Carter just
powered enough Infinity Carter is doing
just fine both both of them
together what if there's two Super
Saiyan women how do we destroy it well
I'd rather you didn't you changed your
outfit pretty cool but you might
remember I defeated that armor once
before even the music's coming
back and he's
dead oh come on I thought you were just
warming up get a little of
this what a fun hodge podge of
[__] yeah guess you figured that armor
out what a crazy missley you think
you're building up to some culmination
of a heroic battle together
yeah
no leave it alone you're making it
unstable shouldn't have asked Peggy to
do
this does she know how to use all the
stones already it would seem
okay it's like the secret Invasion
finale very
much just still at all the powers at
once you've lived in solitude far too
long strange youve forgotten there are
more of us than there are of you that's
the
thing oh
what there
aren't
oh let's do
this that's a great
idea I just love how it keeps leveling
up oh my God it doesn't stop I love it
so much I H okay all jokes aside having
to blast this this is a melee an absurd
melee this is so absurd let's
go strange do some strange [__] come on
look how beautiful of a shot that
it's Captain
C always the soldier out of
time it doesn't have to end this way
don't get me wrong guys there are some
narrative flaws with this episode but
there's so much fun that's happening
that it's making up
for
it was like when um strange fought
Thanos in a way yeah yeah butterflies
all all this to make one super soldier
oh my God we're suddenly taking a big
slowdown
moment Steve is this real what of course
it is the Nazis are on the march across
Europe we need to even the odds seems so
small in comparison to what's going on
with the Multiverse yeah you know it's
going back to urin just
Nazis stay we'll finish the fight we'll
win the war you and me Peg we can
finally be together but if you change
this point in time the butterfly effect
and the butterflies yeah I don't get it
it's does it mean a subtle metaphor Greg
I'll explain it
after I wish that were
true but
you you're not him is this trying to get
her to give up
yeah
huh huh she has strength and
speed see what you've
chosen oh no he's begun he's beating
them to the forge I just wish the
motivation of Strang is rooted in
something else isolation Madness yeah I
mean she's just redoing the same [__] he
was doing last time yeah the same same
motivation the protection around the
forge is weakening I can it's back
peddling to me it is to episode eight of
last season yeah like I don't mind him
being like dark and Sinister but uh I
just wish it wasn't this like bring for
Ste
back yeah the exact
same
whoa but man there's some really fun
[__] happening right before my eyes
right now look how beautifully animated
this is and all these characters we've
met and
experienced neat trick but you see I
mastered that one a long time ago it's
just a game of
tops it's a lot of toys smashing
[Music]
together my world must be reborn or
countless others will die
uh what when was that
explained oh he snapped re Choice Peggy
Carter they will feed my
machine that is so monstrous just
feeding Heroes to the machine just lives
and you my friend are finished not
entirely oh another power
up girls get it done give him give him
hell men
help look they're still being Heroes as
are falling to their deaths the 10 Rings
me oh this is cool all the weapons
coming together Legendary Weapons that's
cool as they're fly to their death
they're giving up their weapons one
final fight beautiful what happened to
all the strangers she butter fly them
away that's
right there's so much happening I
forget what do you mean it's been very
[Music]
linear
what is happening right now this is
insanity just keep going show more
things more keeping keep it going just
your tumble weed man look at look at
what she looks like what this [__] is
going
[Music]
[Applause]
on it's just a fun infinite helic Carter
this is a snowball effect of epic
proportions look at this [__] he has M
and the 10 rings in offense and
defense W he's a vampire with horns oh
he's becoming the thing he
feared oh he's that thing from episode
four he's already that thing whoa it's
already in yeah yeah yeah it's just
unveiling it right nothing is ever over
strange if you're in there you need to
listen to me no you will
listen I I want to compare to to the
secret Invasion finale but I'll I I got
to tell you why this is so much better
afterwards oh it's better but it has
problems similar no but
this strange this isn't you it is
me smiley
face my
God
the
bog all right she's lost all the
buildups I love how it's like a real
game of tops though yeah of how whenever
you think it's over the the other
opponents got one more up their sleeve
pgy so it just culminates in this crazy
cacophony of
[__] whoa that lookes
[Music]
down smash into his
mouth or his nose whatever that body
part
is kind of looks like Mr
Sinister did you punch the evil out of
him it's all it takes it's like Amnesia
it's going to explode come on strange
there has to be a way to stop it I can't
my grief is too strong Christine
wouldn't want this but we
do oh this grief is manifested into a
completely separate being yeah
I always thought that it was just an
extension of him but it's like their
character is
grief yeah like the Shadow Self is this
demon so I guess it didn't completely
undo his
Arc
[Music]
strange I don't know now I'm kind of on
that path of like I was saying I wish
there was the different motivation but
he was he don't get over something it's
true just gets bigger that is true
though he was obsessed and he didn't
seem to get over it at the end it just
felt repetitive in the moment I take it
this means I'm not dead no and neither
is cordi I sent her back to her home
universe that maliciousness didn't go
away in that episode yeah yeah but in
the moment of introduction sure it's
like well we've had this yeah but like
villains have motivation that repeats
itself because that's their motivation
like yeah it's true that's Christine
strangest F worked yes but at the cost
of his life he recreated this universe
but was never born into it and never
will be that is
tragic you saw it didn't you the forge
kahori the monster in strange oh he
didn't just see it he watched it we
nearly lost everything but we didn't the
Multiverse didn't need me to intervene
Peggy it just needed you this is just
Peggy show yeah this was her through
line season right like there was nobody
needs some struggle though got not going
lie it's the one part of season 2 has
been a little bit hard for me it's like
I I really I like her a lot that I don't
love her because I feel like there's a
lack of struggle perhaps we could take
the scenic route home surely there's
something worth seeing along the way
just you watch season
three for bad I do oh my God what
yes are they going to go into the
they're actually going to be connecting
it now I mean that's the same tree of
life that's the same of life
right dude I still I still look man I
can logically see some [__] but I'm not
I'm not going to lie and I would not lie
to you guys I would not lie to you guys
I totally think you guys should buy a
shirt from real reject store reation
shop.com you got it and I'm just going
to say it while we wait for a postcard
scene that we got a shirt like our Pedro
Pascal one last got a recently Doctor
Who shirts full of a whole bunch of
Doctor Who quotes on the Tardis uh we
got space babies of the Galaxy we got a
billion of them and it is one of the
absolute best ways to support the
channel Co apparently owns a bunch and
they're all living in his closet like
they good somebody puts his clothes away
and then I had a charity event today so
you're giving me ex about helping people
go home between I came wear you can't
wear a real reject shirt that's
Christmas I wore a Christmas sweater
here I am I know I know post credit
scene you we wait for post credit scene
before we review and I'll say this all I
want to say is while I recognize some
narrative flaws I think there's to
review there's so much things in here
that I'm just not going to go into the
details yet there's so much things in
here that while I can compare it to
other things that did why it didn't work
of what I liked it I I had so much fun
with this I I genuinely was like this
was a blast I I I kind of wouldn't have
it any other way except for 20 minutes
longer just to flesh out I would like
the few more episodes to be 5 minutes
long youie Jesus Christ not what
going tradition and how it's done
everyone knows great great soundtrack
just wa enjoying the score just wait
waiting look at all these talented
people ADR done and Burbank just get to
the post credit scene who gives a [__]
Gordon just get to the post credit
special thanks Roy Thomas great great
writer honestly I don't need a post
credit soon we just got to wait to see
if got assume if it doesn't have it if
not we write we take a baseball bat to
Kevin F Here Comes Deadpool Deadpool
Stream post credits it's the next thing
no Echo it's not going to have post
credits I think there's going to be a
post I don't think it's post that's a
good thing we waited to review or maybe
maybe Disney was like Hey not in the
Press we're going to give you screeners
we're not going to give a post credits
what if they do what Sony did that one
time and it's just across the spider
versus the end of Venom and they're just
like here's an echo
scene I I I would be fine with that I
mean I think it might happen in one
week all at once five episodes of
echo uh can we review
now fine all right uh I would say of the
post endgame shows and movies which
includes phase four and the phase five
up into this point this give it to me
blun Koy this makes the top third
there's been like 10 properties and this
makes top third I did not like the
finale as much as the rest of the season
but I did not dislike the finale as much
as I disliked a lot of what season one
so therefore it is much higher than like
my whole what if experience and I really
liked what most of it was uh 1602 I
could have been a finale for me um I I
feel like they could have had strange
across multiple seasons and just be like
a tease I would have been okay with cuz
602 felt like a big culmination Avengers
event I didn't necessarily need the the
the culmination of like ah but it was
fun it just felt a little bit like the
secret Invasion problem where it's like
this girl you just met plus Captain
Carter who doesn't have weak have more
and that became a bit much but overall
um it was worth the fun which I think
was what you kept saying is like the joy
I had far outweighed my brain going like
bit much because they just kept leveling
up the cacophony of excitement and I
love seeing characters that I could
imagine how that what if character came
to be I love the idea of pausing and
finding new things I love the rapid
comic esque stack on stack on stack that
I think Secret Wars is going to feel
like worth the the squeeze but once I
slowed down to think I was like I don't
know about that uh dude yeah I I cannot
disagree with
you I
can but I cannot ah you could hence the
duplicitous The Duality of Greg the
dichotomy of thought the duplicitous
nature of being yeah well okay like with
the Marvels that was an experience for
me where I was like I see the
narrative's problems and I can see how
people have fun with this personally the
problems are so outweighing the fun for
me this is the inverse and for me that's
yeah that's a really good point about
exactly how I'd put it is because
visually it still popped visually it was
still exciting to look at and joy came
out of me let's let's really quickly get
the secret Invasion comparon out of the
way I cannot tell you what the game of
tops was in that game between grav Vic
and and uh oh my God what is her name
Amelia Clark what oh my God what is her
name uh memorable show that is a really
bad sign for us as wait for the show or
for the show because they didn't make us
care about her her name is something
talis's daughter yeah that's sh is a
name gravic versus talis's that's
better this is gonna bug me um Sarah I
can't
no Linda
be what's her name anyway secret
Invasion with Sarah versus gravic what
is her [__]
name was not a good character man just
such a waste anyway yeah um yeah that
that was just like let's just give them
a bunch of powers and then just make it
up as we're going along in the visual
effects Department right that's how it
felt mhm
here there was at least as crazy as it
was the Rhythm was there was it they had
to structure it out and they had to map
it out and they had to at least like
have a drawing board I I don't just mean
like an actual like because they
animated it they had to at least have
like a list of things and go how would
this what would be the one to stack next
what would be the one to stack next they
had to at least have a structure to it
so as much as it was like batshit insane
there was at least an actual game of
tops and the the commitment to how crazy
it just kept going from Once Peggy broke
open all the all all the prisons yeah
once Cabin in the Woods started once
Cabin in the Woods started it did not
let go I loved just how Relentless it
became because if it it at least
embraced the relentlessness that's what
I'll say if it didn't have that part of
its soul that I cuz you're either going
to have ass it or you're not going to
meet it all the way and if and if if if
the fact that they met it all the way is
I thought was the Saving Grace for
something that was like yeah these two
girls way too overpowered this two thing
right here this was strange kind of
comes out of nowhere and when you think
about it because the buildup to it
wasn't felt for this season it was in
last season which was years ago and I
did like that it in the in the Avengers
you gather a team and they had the team
already gathered in each episode so I
like that the weapons are gathered
throughout the season like a Dungeons
dragons campaign like I like that you
got a weapons Origins that way when it
all came together it was about the items
and that allowed the overpowering to at
least have some narrative structure like
you're describing with the blueprint
like you have all that so at least it
felt like oh they were planning it from
the beginning not like okay we've
reached the finale what the [__] like it
felt like a journey then the killmonger
tease from season one Cliffhanger even
though it soled in s seconds like that's
what I mean there's just so much but
that's part of the problem I do have is
they were like oh exactly I'm like you
guys set up something and then you're
like what if this op Duo well I in
season one they don't tease with strange
being back going back to the villainous
route no but I mean they kind of allude
to the idea that he's still evil
underneath I felt that it ended with
like I don't trust him well I think for
this particular season of how they've
built in strange he looks like Jafar the
way they don't trust that guy well the
way they're building him up with his
little appearances here so there's
something contextually that I'm like oh
I kind of like the idea of like it's a
mislead like you think he's building up
to assemble towards a greater threat but
it's not actually he the greater threat
yeah he's the greater thre but that also
ties into him killing people in this Kil
like that worked for me yeah yeah yeah
yeah like there's there's stuff
contextually like about it and I found
my way back to I I could see why
narratively he of course he wouldn't be
over this Christine thing but I thought
as a character he had like kind I buy I
I buy like forever Doctor Strange is
being like Christine okay like forever
like that's just like who he's going to
and he would do this Choice 100% okay
all right so that how arrogant
egotistical Doctor Strange is he would
assume he would find a way weirdly
narratively that was the part of it I I
just wish it was somewhat of a my
problem was like if Captain America or
Thor were the character that suddenly
had all those Powers at the end of a
thing people be like and then they have
a new character we just met plus a
character we haven't had a lot of time
to invest it and being like it it just
felt oh totally so I didn't mind the
doctor strange as much as I minded the
like what power don't you have battle
which could work with Doctor Strange in
a version but not with like how did she
learn how to do the infinity stuff like
when did that happen and like those
things definitely bothered me enough but
not enough to throw me out I was still
like shiny like I like we said the
inverse of secret Invasion where it's
like I'm having more joy than my brain
is overthinking yeah the shiny was tasty
enough that I was not like ooh bitter
like I was in like yay yeah the cotton
candy was good yeah I and I'm not just
being forgiving like I I will level with
you we had a cynical year we'll level
with you when we hate like I really
don't give a [__] no I mean we've been
very open about all of our like recent
disappointments CU yeah this is there
this there's so many narrative problems
with this and you might even completely
be in the comments disagreeing with what
we're saying are narrative problems
that's totally fine I still had a great
time this was still a lot of fun so John
got out of nowhere a couple months ago
John was just going sure sure sure he he
was not doing that it just always stood
out to me and I'm like I think you got
it from you that's an expression I do I
also doing it for years yeah I started
doing it in Rocky Horror like five years
back the origins of my sure well I also
that's when I started saying tight tight
tight tight tight I remember like two of
my catr no cuz a kid that was doing the
play with me started doing it for
Brooklyn 99 I it up from him and then I
saw a clip of Brooklyn 99 I was like
that Thief but I I stole it from him he
does yeah yeah so he does ti ti ti I was
like clever but yeah I sometimes have
little roots of my like Expressions that
I tie to memories to events and like
sure was like back in the Rocky era fun
fact this is for the patrons no this
isn't the YouTube video man but uh yeah
I I definitely feel like there were
enough issues to mention them but not
enough issues to have it be a a negative
like it bothered me but the episode was
still a blast if that makes sense like
it's not as good as the rest for me it
would sorry sorry to interrupt I I just
know I just know forget KY promise I'm
sorry I just know forget it would it
would be more um bothersome if this show
wasn't only semi serialized you know
what I mean like these other shows we're
talking about where the when the finale
drops the bomb narratively is because
that's a serialized show yeah this is
only semi serialized at the end of the
day they're all even the serialized ones
are meant to be in mythology of some
kind like the continuation of Peggy
Carter story of the different places
she's hopp in between while she's been a
through line and
inconsistency it's still an anthology
episode and because of that I'm not like
you ruin this you know yeah I agree and
and I do think that I'm okay enough with
like I think it's more exciting for me
to watch five to seven movies get to the
point where Cap wields me only then it
is for me to get to the end of a series
where every weapon we've discovered is
all all beaten used by one character I'd
rather it be a slowburn one buildup but
if you're gonna do it committing to it
like you were describing this is the
best version of that they could have
done and that's why I think it's not
quite secret Invasion but it is
something where I would have rathered it
ended smaller or even ended with 1602
and then go to season 3 with Doctor
Strange buildup
then it does it does lower this season
from like it was an a to a minus for me
now it's like a nice solid a minus it
does it does affect my experience okay
yeah man I'm right uh I'll let you have
that yeah it's not I mean an A minus is
still great it's four stars out of five
like this was a very enjoyable
experience but um yeah that did bother
me a little bit my main issue with with
P like Peggy's an enjoyable character to
watch she's enjoyable to watch my main
issue is again I keep bringing this up
the struggle man like like sure okay in
the game of tops is she like having a
technical struggle with beating strange
yes it's more of just like the nothing
seems to really wear and tear at her you
know she doesn't really seem to get
exhausted she doesn't really seem to get
the reason I can do this all day is
exciting is because cuz he's cuz he's
struggling to keep going yeah and the
reason is because he's like I will do
this exactly that's what makes a great
fight that's what makes that's why you
root for John Wick it's why Mission
Impossible wasn't as fun for us because
Tom Cruz was going through a CGI
landscape and didn't have any that's why
ad Mission Impossible three the finale
is exciting cuz he's like I got to bomb
in my head and I got to keep going and
I'm running like crazy through all these
is playing be as good as anyone ever has
it's really yeah that's but we had the
same problems with mission impossible as
we do with this I think and uh yeah it's
it's exactly my problems with dead
reckoning my problems with Peggy both
starring Haley Atwell Haley atwell's
dead reckoning and Haley atwell's what
if season two similar parallel issue you
know in the Multiverse of Tom Cruz the
haly Atwell problem really reflects
itself in Doctor Strange battles um has
been a counter batch ever worked with
Tom Cruz they should they should that
would be fun um yeah man like no you're
you're it's and I guess because I've
been at that point with pegy that I'm
just like screw it just give her
everything at this point like she
doesn't really seem that exhausted so
just give her like why is her super
soldier so much more powerful it's Al my
question too with like I love the
episode with I guess we' getting her
name wrong this whole time we we spent a
long time remember she added a little D
in there CI Cort but it might be like a
an accent thing like for like her R we
hadn't heard her speak English and then
it sounded like it was another letter in
there she's been speaking English this
whole time what have I been ra your
racist mind I just
heard I can't
understand out I'm like what is she
saying speak Indian sorry back you know
I don't speak
Spanish guys this is what happens when
you film Nine
episodes just chaos but wor the episode
um uh I don't remember we earned chaos
of episode 9 by filming this all as a
binge I have no idea what we were
talking about uh dead
reckoning something there yeah I enjoyed
it but I definitely want Marvel to slow
down on their overpowering characters my
question is yeah with cohort like I
don't know what she is and why she is
tesseract like like she she is in a day
and age where you know like I
think the sad fact is here's the sad
reality Co and I are obviously the last
crowd to be part of the like [__]
culture mentality right the sad reality
is though when you when you suddenly go
when you like keep introducing female
characters and you keep overpowering
them with little to no effort and then
narratively you don't know what to do
with them so you take Captain Marvel out
of the picture because she's too
powerful I'm like you're not helping
this argument this narrative is only
fueling itself Mery soothing that people
keep pointing out you're not helping it
when when I'm like but as a character
like the Hardy character like I really
liked her I was emotionally invested
when I thought canning killed her I was
like oh my God no way like I really
feared for her so I'm invested in her I
but but then the other side of it's like
why is she so goddamn powerful and then
can't she do Captain Carter too like cap
earning like you brought Milner that
when he picked it up I if he's worthy he
earned it and Peggy here is just like
I'm just a magnet of powers you know and
the Mard is also a payoff for the Age of
Ultron tease maybe and this didn't there
was no time to tease and she's been the
only serialized thing yeah and I enjoyed
the Weaponry getting their little
Origins that was clever but I do feel
like there was no moment of her learning
how to wield the the there's no struggle
there's no struggle like I enjoy
watching them I'm not I do enjoy
watching them but there is that part of
me that steps back and goes why are you
so goddamn powerful and I get when you
say Mary Su you think Star Wars and then
you think Luke Skywalker learned pretty
quick too I think what people say all
the time on how it's a lot of the time
incorrectly applied 100% And then but
I'm acknowledging that male characters
have that problem too absolutely
especially in comics but I just saw
Percy Jackson in the Olympians with the
movie I was like this Percy Jackson's
Mar this guy this Gary Su just learned a
lot totally Mar but I do think that we
we have had a lot of female characters
uh have not given the time to breathe as
they should have I think it's more of a
writing issue than it being a woman
issue I think it's like okay we've got
these new characters and go and it's
like no no give them time like let them
flourish I'm pretty sure Kathleen
Kennedy kicked in the door on Marvel she
was like said you make woman Ray yeah
woman Ray we lost Daisy Ridley make
every woman Ray I love Ray Ray she's
back I do love Ray back maybe that's my
unpopular opinion but I love Ray I think
she's great yeah I think Bill burd's the
best character in Star Wars since Empire
man Mandalorian Bill burp Planet Boston
is the best place in the Galaxy oh yeah
totally that character is so good that's
the Stormtrooper sag I wanted from Finn
Mayfield Mayweather Mayfield Mayfield I
think it's Mayfield yeah Mayweather's a
boxer but I think Mayfield is the arc we
wanted from Finn Mayweather could be a
character day could be a character and
Skywalker Mayweather a lot of weather
sensibilities a lot of Sky elements my
point being I want a character whether
it's Storm Trooper like Bill bur or if
it's a character like Captain oh you're
right Emperor Imperial officer right
like he yeah oh [__] you remembered
something yeah down I'm ready no I'm not
uh but whether it's the character that
we assume is 2D it's more exciting to
see a character we assume is 2D become
three dimensional Allah Bill bur
Imperial officer getting that like time
to shine than it is to see a character
get more and more powerful and then
never have a moment to waiver and I
don't feel like that's the one thing
about this season I do wish we had was a
little bit more moment of failure w ing
second thought like as soon as you Dr sh
was bad there was like a pause okay I'm
going to take out Doctor Strange there
was not a there was I just I wanted that
from the character and I think it is
fueling the certain YouTube channels
that Pride themselves on
hate yeah it's true it's just it just
puts Marvel in a bad position oh God if
we could just become one of those
channels money we' make oh man we'd be
so rich I just don't yeah like it'd be
twice as profitable maybe three times
but at what cost internally one bad
comment away
from these damn Libs turning against us
where I just need to cancel culture I
just need to join the other side yeah
over there waiting right there got
pitchforks their pointy white hats I've
my eyes have been opened opened I don't
get woke get open whatever that works
for what is their Awakening
called thing know I don't know the the
well the blackening is a movie where the
racist inning
not all racist get sleep you know
sometimes I watch some of these videos
of these people and sometimes I feel
like they actually have a good point and
then other times And So It Begins
there's a couple points amongst a lot of
bad points that's the problem is every
so often I'll hear like two good points
out of 20 I'm like I think what you hate
is so much is the is the is the um the
presentation it's think of it like this
on a completely different flip side
people a lot of people hate reaction
videos they'll hate our videos cuz
they'll see our thumbnail and assume
they're all the same video is that yeah
and then they watch the video like oh
there's actually a lot more
discussion moment yeah but they always
look like they're shocked or there's
actually a lot more nuance and
discussion oh they actually didn't even
like this you know and so a lot of times
it's often judged and I think some
people hate that presentation granted
our presentation is not negative most of
the time most of the time yeah and I
think what you don't like the most is
the negative presentation right right
even if there's a positive idea yeah cuz
I think some Sometimes some of these
people I won't say who uh some one in
particular who I was like let me Venture
into this person's videos and I was like
oh boy these are really well-made videos
and I'm like with the presentation will
always lump them into the certain camp
that you were talking about where
sometimes those people who present also
Fain in their videos hate and the same
and they're outo but they're profiting
off the hate yeah yeah so I think which
is more Shilling in a different way but
sometimes yeah which is heroically dark
Shilling they're Shilling to their
Market not the studio I hope I made my
point clear without name dropping anyone
specific but I think I understand but
it's like evil chilling is still just as
big a problem when you're trying to
Plate an angry mob you're still doing a
thing where it's being an authentic but
sometimes there is a a Nuance that I
think can gets lost in the anyway
doesn't matter I'm saying a broken
clock's right twice a day sometimes you
say enough [__] you got some wisdom in
there but if you're [__] 10 out of 12
clock [__] I'm saying sometimes you got
to open the video koi and go wait a
minute this is actually a good video but
you won't give it a shot I don't like
YouTube called very much I yeah who the
[__] does that's what I'm saying why
would I why would I spend time going oh
suffer it's it's the worst I don't like
it but I I like connecting with people
that consume positive content on YouTube
but that feels like it's a dying art on
YouTube because because what we're
talking about like we just both admitted
how much more money would be so it's
hard to be like yeah YouTube but it's
like the one good thing which is
intelligent discourse is the thing
that's less popular well dude no it's
time to start hating on everything I
mean I've learned to post on Twitter and
just do it the three dots and go mute
and walk away now I literally I mute
every thread because I know the more
controversial the better it'll do and
the less I'll want to be involved so
it's the worst to be like let me use
this platform of evil I know that feel
so it's like I don't want YouTube to
become that I feel like it is yeah well
but while we're here check out shirts at
nerd rot.com nerd Riot that's a
different website I know no reation
shirts.com I uh no reation shop no one
here remembers the name of the store
reject Nation Oh yeah is re ation
shop.com I can picture the logo now yeah
reation what do you think of the finale
they let you down did you love it do you
watch ntic videos you made it the whole
time you said nerd Riot you just said
nerd rtic yeah yeah yeah oh
[__] I'm like we did such a good job hey
man you know uh your boy blocked me on
Twitter I went to go see what Tyrone was
about and he like [__] I preemptively
blocked me like guess I won't learn he
preemptively blocked you did you call
him out earlier we mentioned him in one
of your one of our lives and I was like
yeah I hear that guys and I was like oh
but he just like block me all [__] I was
like I guess I'll never learn it's okay
it's right it was funny he was crying
about some like not going to Disneyland
he was too woke and I like went to go
like look at the video to see if it was
actually I was trying to give him a
chance and then I was like I guess I
can't that's about what it's about what
the video is I literally was trying to
do what you just described where you
were like I'm going to give this a
chance and see if there's new on and I I
clicked I was like I will not be this
about it's a funny video I couldn't
watch
Internet it's a lovely Place have a good
[__] holiday uh it is New Year's in a
couple days may your New Year be merry
gay and bright this is for the sink
Happy New
[Music]
Year